he's the captain of his Youth Hockey Club he's
on the bench for the first period tonight with
the Flyers as the honorary team captain and
we'll show you even more of the experience
that the Flyers had put on highquality scoring
opportunities for either team in the first five
as faraby gave it away and moving It Is AO puts
on the break that's the best shot we've seen so
far aiser off the right pad of Carter Hart good
job by Dmitri orof to pick the pocket of faraby
who looked like he might jump right across the
Carolina [Applause] line AO with a drop long rer
from Jaylen Chatfield B on net AO puts it in
the blue paint save the rebound scar Michael
bunting breaks the ice here in Philadelphia he's
promoted up to the top line with Sebastian AO and
just like that he's got his fifth of the Season
had one Rush came back and as you mentioned a
play was broken up and then watch this pass just
over to Jaylen Chatfield a quick long range shot
chatfield's a little more defensive but what the
canes do well is they jump on all the rebounds
and they're able to Coral the puck they get it
from outside and they're able to put it inside
and buntings there in a perfect spot you know if
you watch the way AO passes that it's it's off the
heel of his stick it's amazing they are 111 and0
when they score the first goal and 08 and one when
the opposition scores first first that was a um
you look you mentioned Lemieux in the lineup has
haven't played for a couple weeks but he's there
a couple good opportunity offensively a little
over eight minutes gone by in the opening period
as Tyson Forester gained the Zone a little 360
wheel around backhander right back to his deepart
Midway through the first Ashi again couldn't get
it past DeLorean flotten down in the right wi
corner off the Blocker of cachette golf from a
nearly impossible angle and lifted free by peshi
a bouncing Puck off the shinguards of sanheim and
he will chase it down York back hands one off the
near glass chopped Center Circle by lton there is
sanim stepping in and he'll Fork it deep and hop
over the boards all five Flyers change good play
there by sanheim get down low uses his glove to
make sure that bouncing Puck doesn't get by him
he knew they needed a change Grant Burns moves
in shoot save made by har it'ss the high glass
over the top of the net of ketov anus gave it away
connect down low vananh to the again and kept it
out of the talked about him in the open he's been
offensive for this team check this out he comes in
not only takes this chance here and the whole team
is supporting him but he stays down low he ends
up getting the puck back and it's great work by
kkny to give it back to him and what a great play
to try to come back terab gets that sa he sweeps
it right back to York straight away York to the
back backand around NIS puts it down low between
the legs cier sanheim tried to pull one and Tow
dragon that was denied and after that teravan
takes a shot but you think coov gets a save for
terrain stick there probably not coov just got
another save on the opportunity ha Atkinson tip
it with a rer that sails just why where could
it be more right a better fit for any team than
with the man advantage and maybe just that right
not playing top six minutes but just getting out
there and being a Power Play specialist face
off to the right of Carter Hart one by stall
Burns wrist shot CH save is made by Hart and he's
able to control the rebound Jason in as he puts a
shoulder and York behind the net K the Palin on
that blocker save made by ceto and a two-on-one
short-handed AO and Jarvis across the AO shoot
save made by Hart moving from right to left on
the doorstep sweeping ping is Jarvis a bang pass
ahead to n into the corner stall sweeps it around
the boards back to Burns long snapshot off the
Blocker of heart and a possible Breakaway Here
Comes conne SC what an out left pass and conect
sneaks behind the K's defense that's the game at
one goal finished by Travis concy but it starts
all way back in their defensive Zone it's a big
rebound and it's and a great heads up play by
Forester the rebound comes him he already knows
that he's got connect he busting down to the far
blue line so a quick retrieval of that rebound
which is bouncing a little bit and you know we
talked about their power play Wes they only have
seven Power Play Goals on the season two of
them come came from connec a turnover stall
with a look and an arm save made with either the
shoulder or right blocker by Carter Hart in the
opening period and connecting with an answer here
in the second long rer from stall sails just wide
rist Alan pinches in behind the net controls the
puck wheel around rer from a hard angle the chck
off was ready they usually allow an average of 25
a game and they are number one in the NHL inest
shots allowed per game and here's a giveaway
and a right pad save made by Carter Hart said
these goalies are going to figure it out they're
going to start getting better better numbers and
there eight goals that Ron gave up to Tampa Bay
certainly didn't help his numbers throwing one
out in front is n that's blocked in on har the
rebound score inserted into the lineup Brendan
Lemieux in place of the ill Andre smov and look
who puts the puck in the back of the net it's
Lemieux and that gives Carolina the lead back jump
on loose pucks and they retrieve loose Pucks in
this Bo batter this is the fourth line we were
talking about Drury masan and Lemieux inserted
but they're just hard work along the wall and
there is a funny caram off a skate here right
now it's a rebound and you can see the the puck
is trying to be cleared there by Scott lot and
right here it goes off Lemieux's Shin pad quick
reaction save and then Lemieux just Feats lot
to that loose Puck so that's just a hardworking
ship that's what this line has done really well
a Rolling Puck hops off his stick right back
to the neutral zone Brewery and there's one
right back in for Jarvis centering pass oh that's
shot on net by AO steered aside by har fluid play
too the way AO plays it you got to always you
never know where he's going to go right to the
net backand one and AO puts it on that heart able
to make the save this is just on the Zone entry
too you you watch the way the terraining comes
in he's got AO with him and it's a great play
sanheim answers brings it right back in carries
behind the net look to Center one instead does a
LAP back to the point long wrist side of the net
wrap around try stop with the stick by to check
off he's guys barab it's in the far corner and it
looked like he struggled with that deflecting rer
in spite of how far away it was launched from
Jarvis after it some open Ice sanan closes the
distance score a rer by Jarvis snuck under the
left pad of Carter Hart it looked like he had
it and almost kicked it into his own net and
it's a twogo lead for Carolina pouring on the
pressure at the other end of the ice and you can
see the Flyers are converging they've got to take
risks at this point in the season excuse me this
point in the game they go down jvis afterburners
on getting that puck he has Travis sanheim who
we talked about how great he's been angling him
sanheim plays that well he's shoulder-to-shoulder
with him forces gate back to kick it instead puts
it in the net well the net empty that shot by
teravan was blocked now the Flyers need a pair
and that is an empet goal thrown in from the half
wall left wing side that will make this a 4-1
lead and congratulations for KI as that is about
as easy as they come that will put Carter heart
back in his neck honestly I beg to differ easy as
they come Bob I'd like to see you do that where
he's sitting over there on the side he's a left
shot so his angle a little tough he's got pressure
here he gets his eyes up between the legs and he
threads the needle so granted no goalie there but
still that's ESPN Plus Hulu exclusive coming up
a couple of nights from now Ferraro and Steve
Levy will have the call as the canes will take
on the Islanders another team and right now they
are in the general vicinity of in the Eastern
Conference playoff picture but the final 41